avenges endgame clocked in at a whopping
three hours making it the longest Marvel
movie to date but there are still scenes
that were cut from the final film that
we never got to see yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers I'm Shannon in this video I'm
revealing all the deleted and fake
scenes from endgame a new round of my
Marvel giveaway is also running so
subscribe and leave a comment about the
movie for a chance to win of course
we'll be discussing spoilers so take
care if you haven't seen the film yet if
you were devastated by Black Widows
heroic sacrifice and endgame you'll be
shocked to know that a stack of natascha
scenes were cut from the final film
first is a deleted scene of NASA target
practice where she's keeping her
shooting skills sharp another cutscene
of Nats training has her punching a
boxing bag showing her relentless
determination to keep going and in
another cutscene of NAT sitting by
herself in the rain we can see how
lonely she is all those deleted scenes
throw more light on how Black Widow was
really the only original Avenger who
refused to give up on the mission over
the five-year time jump
although the Avengers hunt Thanos down
on his garden planet and kill him it
doesn't reverse the snap and so over the
five years of follow Tony Steve Bruce
Clint and Thor all go their own way with
only NAT staying on at Avengers HQ where
she's determined to keep the mission
going with surviving heroes like rocket
a Koi a Captain Marvel and war machine
reporting in to her it would have been
nice to see these deleted scenes to show
what NAT was going through especially
given that she reveals to Steve and
Clint that the Avengers were her one
true family but I suspect they were
likely cut for time as I can see they
weren't absolutely essential for the
story another deleted scene for Black
Widow comes later during the time-travel
portion of the movie when she and
Hawkeye are on their way to warmia
there's a clip cut from the final film
where NAT and Clint seem to be taking a
moment before they head on down to the
soulstone planet and it looks like this
was probably some additional
foreshadowing of Nats eventual fate and
a small moment from the first trailer of
Natasha looking on in shock at the
carnage that Hawkeye is unleashed on the
Yakuza in Tokyo was also chopped from
the final movie we all know already from
Avengers infinity war that Marvel loved
to use fake and deleted scenes and
trailers to throw fans off the scent
when trying to figure out spoilers and
in Avengers endgame Marvel have dialed
up the level of mister
trickery 211 for example in the final
battle during Captain America's fight
with Thanos the mad Titan repeatedly
brings down his huge double bladed sword
on cap shield
smashing it several times and leaving
only part of it intact but to avoid
revealing this in the trailers when we
see cap dragging himself up from the
ground his shattered shield has been
replaced with an unbroken one in another
shot from the battle when cap Tysons the
shield strap on his arm as he readies
himself to face off against Thanos again
in the movie the shield is broken at
this point but in the trailer we see it
still in one piece an infinity war Bruce
Banner wasn't able to summon his inner
Hulk successfully but in endgame during
the five-year time jump banner finally
comes to terms with the green guy and
rather than trying to treat him as a
disease he embraces him and becomes
Professor Hulk getting what he calls the
best of both worlds
to avoid this reveal before the movie
was released Marvel digitally removed
help from any scenes in the marketing
materials in this scene where rocket and
banner go to new Asgard to find Thor in
the movie professor Hulk is actually
right behind rocket as a raccoon opens
the door but in the trailer he was
digitally erased and in this scene where
war machine meets ant-man in the movie
professor Hulk walks into the scene but
in the TV spot the big green guy was
removed another major character change
that Marvel wanted to hide pre-release
was Thor's transformation from a bicep
busting hero to an overweight depressed
god of thunder or what the internet is
calling fat Thor although Thor went for
the mad Titans head when they found him
on the garden planets afterwards he fell
into a deep depression abandoning his
role as ruler at the Asgardians and
instead playing video games with meek
and Korg while eating tons of junk food
and drowning his sorrows and beer so
when Marvel presented us with shots of
Thor with his bat already infinity
warlock in the trailers it was a
complete misdirect for other endgame
trailer scenes they completely removed
the Asgardian gods so he wouldn't see
the oh who ate Thor in this scene of The
Avengers figuring out their time heist
plan both Thor and professor Hulk have
been digitally erased from the shot in a
similar bit of trailer trickery Thor and
Hulk were removed from this shot of the
team walking towards the time-travel
machine the Avengers facility
another attempt at misdirection is how
Marvel edited this shot of thought to
make it look more like he was somewhere
like Wakanda in the movie this scene
actually takes place after Thor killed
Thanos on his farm but in the trailer
the surrounding background has been
altered to give us a different look
there's some scenes teased in a TV spot
that were deleted from early in the
movie where Captain Marvel is with the
team and they're looking at screens of
missing heroes Carole Stephen Rhodey are
all wearing the same clothes they had on
in a scene which was in the movie where
Captain Marvel proposed is going to
sound off sis garden planet to take the
Infinity stones back and there's also a
similar deleted scene from a trailer
where banner is looking at screens of
Scott Lang Sheree and Peter Parker who
are missing it's also strange the end
game is missing any mention of Nick
Fury's pager from the infinity war
post-credit scene Marvel kind of
addressed this by releasing the
post-credits scene from Captain Marvel's
movie just before and the game came out
tell me the second you get a signal I
want to know who's on the other end of
that thing
where's fury it's still surprising this
post-credit scene of Carol meeting the
team wasn't included an end game with
maybe some additional footage of her
learning about the snap because the
Russo brothers have previously used
post-credit scenes from other Marvel
movies in their own films
for example the Bucky post-credits scene
from ant-man appeared in Captain America
Civil War just before the Avengers split
off into teams to visit different
timelines and retrieve the Infinity
stones from the past cap gives them all
a pep talk and they put their hands
together in a circle for the trailers
though the time heist devices that
they're each wearing on their gloves
have been removed by the way suitably
enough this shot is an Easter Egg to a
New Avengers comic book in which
Marvel's Illuminati discussed the
existence of a multiverse and multiple
parallel realities and to avoid giving
away more clues about end games time
travel in the trailers Marvel disguised
the fact that this scene takes place in
2012 during the Battle of New York in
the movie Steve is wearing his blue
Captain America outfit from the first
Avengers film and not his infinity war
costume that we see here you trust me I
do
and the handshake between Tony and Steve
at the end of that clip was also cut
from the final film to avoid giving much
away about the film's third act Marvel
made a huge number of changes to any
scenes and the trailers taken from the
final battle against Thanos in this
scene of Iron Man cap and Thor walking
towards the mad Titan Thor's hammer
Mjolnir has been erased the existence of
Mjolnir an end game and how Thor
acquired it by going back in time to
Asgard needed to be kept secret as
before endgame the hammer was last seen
in Thor Ragnarok where Heller destroyed
it this brief clip of Hawkeye fleeing
down a burning tunnel should actually
show out riders engulfed in the flames
behind him but to avoid revealing that
Marvel scrubbed them out of the trailer
Clint was also carrying the new gauntlet
with the Infinity stones at this point
in the film another detail that was
wiped out of the trailer during this
scene of rocket and war machine
assembling with cap and the other heroes
giant man is also rising up behind them
except in the trailer he's been removed
Captain Marvel has a couple of new
haircuts an end game which rocket makes
a joke about early on in the movie but
the shorter star which Carroll sports
after the five year jump was replaced in
the
sailors with captain Marvel's helmet a
mohawk as previously seen in her solo
movie and hair related misdirections
weren't limited to captain Marvel's role
in endgame marbles marketing team even
went so far as to change black widows
her length style and color in this
trailer clip were Nazis ant-man on the
video camera arriving at the Avengers
facility she still got her blonde Bob
from infinity war even though it happens
five years in the future but in the
actual movie at this point Natasha's
hair is long loose and mostly red mix
with some blonde by the way Scott's
lines from the trailer where he asked to
be buzzed in was also deleted from the
film the character who never showed up
an end game and who many fans missed was
vision whose son was killed before the
snap in infinity war concept art of a
ghostly gray white vision leaked before
endgame suggesting we might have seen
the Android return many fans had
theorized that vision would come back an
endgame because when he was killed an
infinity war he was drained of his
colour a possible allusion to the
transformation of his character in the
comics after he was resurrected by Hank
Pym but even though vision didn't appear
an endgame he is returning to the MCU a
Scarlet Witch in the not-too-distant
future
another technique Marvel used to try and
prevent secrets from leaking out was by
giving actors notorious for leaking
spoilers only partial scripts in an
interview with E News Mark Ruffalo
revealed that he shot five different
endings for the movie I like shot five
different endings I didn't even get a
whole script I don't know why I even got
the script I did get had-had dummy
scenes in it and I've got a separate
video on that and how despite all that
Ruffalo still managed to accidentally
leak the actual ending of Avengers
endgame many weeks before the film was
released tapping the top of the screen
to check that out or there's a link in
the video description a cameo which
appears to have been cut from end gamers
by thirteen reasons why stark Catherine
Langford he was rumored to playing one
of two possible characters in the movie
the first was Kate Bishop one of the
Young Avengers in the comics who became
Hawkeye at a time when Clint wasn't
around
Kate Bishop also worked with Clint for a
while after he returned and if Langford
did film something is possible it was
more a teaser for Hawkeye's upcoming TV
series on Disney Plus which Variety says
will show Clint passing
Hawkeye mantle on - Kate bishop before
end games release another rumor was that
Langford would play Tony Stark's
daughter Morgan this doesn't line up
with the fact that Morgan Stark was only
five years old and endgame so that rumor
seems unlikely unless she was meant to
appear to Tony as a vision of an older
Morgan in a flash-forward or dream when
fans of the actress asked her what her
character was supposed to be an end game
she simply replied with a mysterious
dot-dot-dot
so do you wish any of these deleted
scenes have been included in Avengers
end game and what do you think about
many of the scenes and the trailers
being faked or digitally edited comment
below and be sure to subscribe to enter
my Marvel giveaway congratulations to
the winner the first round of the
giveaway send me a message from my about
page so I can send you the prize tapleft
to check out how Ironman actually
predicted the ending of Avengers end
game or tap right for that Mark Ruffalo
video or another video you're sure to
like and if you enjoyed this a thumbs up
and a share are hugely appreciated
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers